plus de deux cent trente cavaliers
étaient présents ce week-end pour
participer au premier concours
international de sky équitation trois
jours de compétition avec trois
disciplines différentes
le jumping le cross et le dressage pour
des cavaliers amateurs ou professionnels
venus du monde entier six nations
représentées des belges des italiens des
espagnols
un chilien alors on est assez
enthousiaste parce que on a monté ce
projet avec toute l'équipe du centre
équestre de saint quentin et est les
cavaliers ont répondu présent et on a un
très beau week-end qui se déroule martin
vient du centre de la france
accompagné de son cheval diabolo dems
pour eux le concours de sky équitation
leur permet de clore la saison qui a
commencé début mars c'est la première
fois que je viens mais c'est aussi la
première fois qu'ils font un concours
international et on est vraiment plutôt
enchanté de l'accueil des terrains de
l'organisation dressage le cros hier
était très agréable à parcourir et en
bon cheval s'est très bien comportée
donc c'était c'était en plus très
positif pour moi mais le cso c'est cet
après midi on va voir ça je pense que
c'est aussi un très beau parcours
l'objectif de cette compétition est
atteint pour le directeur du centre
équestre qui souhaite à l'avenir garder
ce concours et le développer pour
accueillir d'autres cavaliers ainsi que
de nouvelles épreuves
moi j'ai très à coeur qu'on garde cette
compétition internationale l'année
prochaine qu'on la fasse grandir
et puis qu'on continue surtout à
développer centre équestre et poney club
puisque faut pas oublier que c'est ses
400 adhérents
maintenant qu'ils viennent pratiquer
l'équitation toutes les semaines qui
étaient là hier qui ont vu cette
fabuleuse compétition est ce qu'on a
envie nous c'est vraiment se monter ce
projet de développement ouvrir
l'équitation plus grand nombre proposer
des grands événements et faire en fait
que toute la la famille cheval se
retrouvent ici et pas désagréable moment
un triathlon équestre internationale qui
sera potentiellement renouvelée pour une
édition 2020 avec comme objectif plus de
cavaliers étrangers